Elizabeth Palmer is in Beijing where  China says it's prepared to retaliate  against US exports Elizabeth Howard  Chinese officials reacting to these  higher tariffs good morning well as you  might expect it's basically a tit for  tat we had news just a short while ago  from the Chinese Commerce in ministry it  says it with regret is going to have to  apply countermeasures and that means  Chinese tariffs on US imports we don't  know how much and we don't know exactly  what goods will be targeted but it's  likely to include US agricultural  products machinery and perhaps even  energy that is to say natural gas  however it's worth noting that the mood  music coming from the foreign ministry  is still pretty constructive it's saying  that it still hopes as latest this  afternoon it was saying this that the US  will meet China halfway on a deal